à quelques centaines de mètres des
bains de jour et de l'usine sucrière, à vol d'oiseau, dans
le creux du ravin de San Jill,
au lieu-dit Pomme bâtarde,
il y a une vanne d'eau bien ajustée dans un
mur de soutènement installé vers 1825 lorsque la
sucrerie pare-soleil a été construite.  construit il est
toujours là malgré quelques
pièces en fonte de son mécanisme où abandonné
au sol cette volonté métallique de plus de
six mètres de diamètre était mise en mouvement par
les seaux se remplissant d'eau provenant
du tuyau situé dans la partie supérieure d'
un système de  engrenage fait de dents les
Wills utilisaient pour démarrer une pompe qui était
aspirée puis renvoyait l'eau
du ravin vers le bâtiment sucrier les
chaudières à vapeur étaient ensuite alimentées en
eau
[Musique]
après la fermeture de l'usine en 1920 le
testament est le seul moyen  pour que le domaine
ait de l'eau potable jusqu'en
1968, son approvisionnement en eau a été réalisé dans le bassin cultivé en usine
ainsi qu'un réservoir d'eau dans
le village à côté de la forme d'esclavage.